I want to get into the book with the
last five minutes that we have homegrown
Timothy McVeigh and the rise of
right-wing extremism what is the premise
behind this book and why'd you choose to
write this
um
the Oklahoma City bombing was April 19
1995.
um
two years later McVay and Nichols went
on trial the trial was moved to Denver
um and I covered the trial I was then
working for ABC and The New Yorker so I
I you know I I was well steeped in the
story but you know time had passed and
you know I never wrote a book about it
in October of 2020 right before the
election
the FBI arrested a group of people who
were plotting to kidnap Governor Whitmer
of Michigan and Terry Nichols who was
the co-defendant in that case was also
for Michigan he was affiliated with the
Michigan militia same same with the uh
um the uh the the people who were
involved in in the kidnapping and I
thought wow this is like you know
similar January 6 happened a few weeks
later so I decided to look at the story
again first of all it's just an
incredible true crime story of how
McVeigh did this and and and I certainly
believe that McVay did do it it's not
like there's some conspiracy that he
didn't do it he certainly did it and and
the way he organized it and the way he
you know got the fertilizer and the J in
the in the um racing fuel and rented the
truck it's just an incredible story but
um McVeigh has since been portrayed as
um someone who was like a lone wolf and
an anti-government person it's not
accurate McVeigh was part of the
right-wing movement of the 90s he was
um someone who was a you know a big Rush
Limbaugh supporter he was a Pat Buchanan
supporter he was
um someone who was obsessed with um the
the supposed fear that the government
was going to take his guns away if you
see that ideology moving forward
um that ideology is it has been enduring
and the difference is that McVeigh
didn't have the inner at in the 90s he
didn't have the ability to communicate
with like-minded people
and
um
those sorts of views are com are a lot
easier to spread now and if you look at
whether it's January 6th or the mass
Shooters in El Paso and South Carolina
in Pittsburgh in Buffalo they are all
mobilized by the internet in a way that
McVeigh couldn't and I want to let
Vinnie talk now because I know he thinks
I'm so foolish I I think you you left
out that McVeigh was a psychotic
murdering Mania he's he's absolutely to
do something like that to kill all those
people you're insane I do agree listen
January 6 some idiots went there and
they did some stupid but one person
died and it was actually bad but she was
a United States military veteran who was
shot and killed and we just found out
again through all the Twitter files how
many FBI agents were down there
basically and I saw the video of Ray
apps it literally yeah follows
undercover FBI agents hadn't been there
January 6th how many more would have
been killed no but what I'm saying is
yelling at people inciting violence and
writing from Agents on the floor agents
let's let's just be honest with each
other pushing people in to go do it one
person died and here's my question Jeff
can you blame can you blame a group of
people that know for a fact that they
already tried to get cheated on on
January 6 I'm sorry uh 2016 election
they know that uh Hillary and everybody
tried to cheat to get Trump out that was
100 cheating why would you blame them to
think that in 2020 they wouldn't try it
again so can you blame people for not
trusting a system and then going
somewhere because I believe in this if
you have a problem with the system you
don't burn down your city you don't do a
BLM did you don't do what antifa does
with your actual terrorists antifa are
domestic terrorists you don't burn down
your city you go to the heart those
people some of them stupid as hell I
agree some of them vandalizing and
beating out of people but when you
have a problem with the system you don't
burn down your city you go to the system
you go to the government and they did
that and I hold on and get it when
people say threat to democracy I I don't
believe that that was a threat to
democracy I think that was a bunch of
pissed off people that were screwed once
and they believed I don't believe it or
not they were like you know what I think
we got treated again and then went to
the heart of the stores the the
protests are completely legitimate and
that's as an American as apple pie
protest but
it's it's not it's not legal or
appropriate or in any way defensible to
break into the case
absolutely that's why we're talking
about I mean we're only talking about
the people in the capital we're not
talking about the people at the economy
who were at Trump's rally you know yeah
and also I think you know we don't know
exactly what went on behind the scenes
but I don't think you can prosecute
Trump for what he said in that speech I
agree he said you gotta fight every
politician says you got to fight right
that's not the Beastie Boys said you got
to fight for your right yes indeed and
who could disagree with that
um because you do have to fight for your
arrest and this is why Vinnie I told you
but when you went to January
but but
um you know the the difference is
crimes committed and you know you can't
commit crimes that that's the that's
what's
um that's you know what to me is
indefensible and you know obviously you
know McVeigh did something far more
egregious obviously but the engaging in
violence and support of your political
position is something that has carried
forward I agree because I think it
listen anybody only one side
far oh and this is this is something
that I you know I deal with in the book
this fantasy that antifa is somehow as
dangerous as the right is is a com is is
a if you look at the statistics 75 of
the political crimes in this country
have been committed by people on the
right antifa is a tiny tiny percentage
compared to to that
I mean from what I've seen every time
the right is trying to do something or
speak or protest or have taught antifa
shows up just to cause havoc and shut
them down because again you have to
silence in Portland and hardly no what
do you mean they just went to Glendale
and they were in Glendale California
because Armenian people were like you're
not going to teach our kids all this
stuff they're underage antifa was there
and they got their asses whooped by The
Armenian community and I salute them I
get messages left and right fact support
what you're saying with the 75 it's in
the book yeah okay
I'm gonna read this book yeah I'm gonna
take this book
political political crimes is what you
just said can you break that down I know
what a violent crime is I know what
aggravated assault is when you say
political crime politically motivated
crimes
crimes you know that that you know like
um the the uh Muslim extremists who shot
up uh I forgot which Ford it was uh the
one of the army bases the the
psychiatrist in Maryland Texas Fort Hood
I mean that was a politically motivated
crime it was you know Islamic terrorism
um right pulling that from the right no
not at all
yeah I'm saying it was not from the
right that if you there there is crimes
from Islamic terrorists there are crimes
from the uh the left antifa and their
crimes from the right people like the
white supremacists who shot up the
Walmart in El Paso the um Dylan roof who
killed the people in South Carolina
church the uh and Pittsburgh the
shooting of the synagogue the grocery
store in in Buffalo those are from the
right that that's those are the sort of
three General categories I'm talking
about and what would you what would you
say because I mean we hear we hear it
all the time from from the left from the
White House from Joe Biden that the
number one threat to the United States
is is white supremacy it's it's those
and and that's what that's what the
numbers show that that's where most of
the most of the threat comes from
because we have my we had two FBI
whistleblowers here and I asked them the
very same question you know what they
both said it ain't it ain't white
supremacies that he's like it's the
actual Insider threat and he goes it's
the government against the people and
that's these guys they were sitting
right where we're sitting right now and
they said that that's what the threat
was he said the percentage these are FBI
agents that the percentage of white
white supremacists walking around
causing problems that's that's not the
that's not the number one problem here
so wow you know if the audience wants to
find out for themselves on the opposing
argument or something they agree with
they can order the book home grown the
Link's gonna be below for you guys to
order once again uh thank you so much
for coming out and being on the podcast
absolutely terrific thank you all your
terrific group and I really am grateful
for the opportunity so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another will
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]